I was convinced that light doesn't actually slow
down in water, and I thought I'd mathematically
proved it too, but then I did the experiment
and reality decided to completely contradict me.
So, I really am wrong. Since then, I've spent
a lot of time trying to figure out why light
actually slows down in water. And the thing is,
it's complicated and I still don't know. I feel
like this is something I've heard about,
like, progressively over the last year,
at various different phases of like, now it
makes complete sense, down to like, oh wait,
if this was true, then does that mean that
you're perfectly cancelling out what the wave
would have been in this, like, strange packet?
That doesn't seem to make sense. And then, like,
there's these waves. Hopefully at this point
you've seen Grant's beautiful explanation of
why light should in fact slow down in water.
Now that argument is based on chapter 31 of the
Feynman lectures, and the thing is, I'd actually
read that chapter before I did the experiment,
and I'd completely believed it as well.
And yet I was still convinced that light
wouldn't actually slow down in that experiment.
The reason is that Feynman's argument shows that
the phase velocity of light decreases when
it goes into water. But phase velocity is
not what most of us mean when we talk about
the speed of light. Imagine that Alice and
Bob want to send a message to each other, and
they've decided that the best way to do that
is by sending some light between each other.
For example, Alice might send a pulse of light
to Bob that has some pre arranged meaning. When
we talk about the speed of light in the setup,
what we clearly mean is the distance.
Divided by the time that it took light
to get from one end to the other. We'll call
this the information speed because it's how
quickly a message could get from Alice to Bob.
And I think that it pretty much intuitively
captures what we mean by the speed of light. The
experiment that I did with the LiDAR on my phone
was very similar in setup to this. My phone
emitted a pulse of light, and we measured how
fast that took to travel through the water.
The result of that experiment was that the
information speed slows down significantly.
So this is the thing that we need to explain.
But in Feynman's book, he considers a completely
different scenario. Instead of sending a short
pulse of light, Alice sends a plane wave, which
is a wave like this. The thing with plane waves
is they're not real. They extend infinitely in
both directions and are the same for all time.
They just keep moving along like this. Which
means that this wave has been here forever,
before Alice and Bob even existed. People
often say that a plane wave is like a pure
color of light, like a laser. But actually these
aren't like lasers at all, because lasers have
to be turned on at a certain point of time and
then they turn off at a certain point of time.
Whereas this is like you had a laser that's always
been on since the start of the universe. That's
what makes them actually completely useless to
Alice and Bob for sending messages. When Bob
sees this light, he's not going to think this is
a message from Alice. He's just going to think,
oh well, it's the same as it always is.
That's why it's not possible to talk about
the usual speed of light or the information
speed of light for a plane wave. Because
there's no time difference between when the
light was at Alice and when it was at Bob.
It's always been there. But, for this type of
wave, there is another way to define the speed.
Look at one of the peaks, and then
look at how fast that peak moves along.
This is what we call the phase velocity.
In physics, we really like to talk about
the phase velocity, not because it's real or a
good measure of velocity, but just because it's
easy to measure. So, for example, in quantum
computing, we often were talking about, like,
phase differences, um, because it's really easy to
figure out if a wave has been shifted like this,
because you can compare it to a wave that
wasn't shifted, and then you can do this,
like, constructive and destructive interference
stuff to figure out how much of a shift it was.
The other reason that physicists love to talk
about phase velocity is because it's far easier to
prove things about plane waves and phase velocity
than it is to talk about more realistic light.
Feynman's proof is about plane waves and it proves
that the phase velocity decreases. But usually,
proofs about plane waves generalise to regular
pulses of light pretty well, um, by using
something called the Fourier transform.
So the Fourier transform, in this case,
claims that any pulse of light can be made
up of a lot of different plane waves added
together. Here I'm going to add a few plane
waves together and look how quickly they
basically become a pulse. Here's 1, 2, 3, 4
and 5 plane waves, basically already a pulse.
Mathematically that is true, but from a physics
perspective, I hate it. I mean, you're saying
that this little pulse of light that I just happen
to turn on and turn off is actually made out of
basically an infinite number of plane waves that
stretch out into infinity in both directions and
have been on since the start of the universe?
and will continue forever. Like, that just,
that's just not true, is it? Let's go over the
main idea of Feynman's proof and I'll explain
why it's enough to show that the phase velocity
does go down. But I'll also explain why I thought
that that proof showed that the information speed
stays the same. So here's the setup of that proof.
Let's say I have this container full of water
and I have this massive light here that's shining
light into the container. If we just look at
the electrons in the first slice of this water,
we'll see that each of them is getting hit by
light. We're assuming the light is coherent,
which means that all of this
is the same kind of light.
You can see that first there's a peak here, and
then there's a trough, etc. Now imagine that we
want to figure out what happens to an electron
that's further down in the water somewhere. If
the other electrons weren't in the way, then it
would only get hit by the light that's directly
in front of it. But it's these other electrons
being here that makes all the difference.
And that's because each one of them is going to
emit their own light in response to the light
that's hitting them. Remember that happens
because when electrons get hit by light,
they oscillate. And when a charged particle
oscillates, it emits its own light, which is in
the opposite direction of the light that hit it.
So you can see this electron light is in the
opposite direction of the original light that hit
it. Um, Grant pointed out that that actually isn't
quite right, because the electrons actually oppose
the total force that they experience, and in this
case there's actually two forces they experience.
So they experience the force from the light,
but they also experience force from the atoms
pulling them back to where they originally were.
And so, depending on which of those two
forces is stronger, the direction of the
electron's light may be in the same direction as
the other light, or it might be in the opposite.
It doesn't really matter for the rest of the
analysis, but I thought that was interesting,
so I wanted to point it out. So the light that
hits this electron further down the line is going
to be a combination of these two bits of light.
Crucially, the light coming from these electrons
isn't just going in the forward direction
the way that this light from the lamp is.
That's because when the electrons oscillate
like this, they emit light in all directions,
although most strongly in the forward direction.
They also do emit some light that's, for example,
pointing this way and going to hit our electron.
If we just look at two of those pieces of light,
you'll see why this is such a big deal.
Initially, these two bits of light are in
sync with each other. Even though they're still
in sync here, it's a very different story when
they get to here. The reason that matters so much
is that you can imagine all of these electrons
sending out messages, but because all of the
messages are being sent at the speed of light,
that means that some messages are
going to look like they're lagging
behind if they're coming from further away.
It's the same effect as when we look into the
night sky, and the further away an object is,
the more it looks like it's in the past. In
the same way, some of these electrons are
going to look like they're really lagging
behind. We can see that when the light
reaches this electron here, this light
is at a peak, while this one is at a trough.
And so they actually kind of cancel each other
out at this point. From the perspective
of this electron, this light is lagging
behind. This electron is seeing that light as
it was in the past. So even though in reality
all these electrons are bouncing in unison, from
the perspective of this electron, it's going to
look like actually they're not in unison and the
further away electrons are further back in time.
The overall effect is that the light is
a little bit shifted backwards from where
it should be because some of the light from the
electrons is old light that is just now reaching
the next layer. It makes sense that if a plane
wave gets [00:09:00] shifted back a little bit
every time it goes through a layer of electrons,
that overall the phase velocity would decrease.
But what about the actual speed of light? Does
that decrease according to this argument? Well, I
didn't think so, because remember firstly that all
of these waves are infinite, so we can't even talk
about when they get to the next electron because
they've kind of always been there. So first,
let's just cut these waves short, which means
that they're only approximations to plane waves.
Now we can talk about how long it takes for them
to arrive at the next electron. But this light,
coming from further away, doesn't arrive
as quickly as the more direct one,
and so it will look like it's going slower than
the speed of light. And that's just because
it went on a less direct route, and it takes
longer for the light to travel that longer path.
However, the strongest bit of the light, which
is the original light, plus the light from the
electron in front, does go on the most direct
[00:10:00] path, and so it will look like it's
travelling at the speed c. And so if this electron
was measuring the speed of light by counting how
long it takes until it gets hit by light, it
would say that the speed of light is still c.
Yes, it will experience other light coming
in later, but for the speed measurement,
all that matters is the speed of the
front of the light, because at that point,
it can confirm that it received a message from
the previous layer. Here's another, maybe simpler
way to see the same argument. I'm going to
deal with just really simple light like this.
It's like I turn this lamp on and off very
quickly. I found it so confusing to the point
of not believing it, that light like this could
really slow down in water. And that's because
of this really simple argument I had, which you
might remember from last time. So here's how it
went. When this light hits these electrons...
The electrons hit back with their own light.
When you sum all of that up, you're going to
get something. It's going to be complicated,
so let's not worry exactly what it looks
like, but it's going to be some light there.
And this is going to happen for every layer. So
whenever the original light reaches a new layer,
it's going to jiggle all of those electrons,
and they're going to immediately respond by
producing some complicated function of light.
Another way to think of it is that whenever
this original light moves into a layer, It
immediately produces some light from the
electrons. So we know the original light is
traveling through the water unimpeded going
at the speed c and we know that it's producing
this electron light as it goes. But when we're
talking about the speed of light in water, what
we actually care about is not the original light.
Or even the electron light, but the
sum of them together. As soon as this
light gets to a particular layer, it will
produce some electron light in that layer,
and that will add to some resulting light.
And so there will be some resulting light
that's in this layer. So the resulting light is
travelling just as fast as the original light
did because they keep in time with each other.
Think about it from the perspective of someone
who is timing how long it takes for some light
that was shone on one side of this container
to get to the other side. They stop timing as
soon as they detect some light, and because
that light was just keeping in time with the
original light, The amount of time it took for
that new light to get across the water is exactly
the same as if there was no water there at all.
This argument seems watertight, but
it's not. It's actually wrong. And
we know that because the experiment showed
that light really does slow down in water.
Morning. So, I spent a lot of time last night
thinking about, um, where I should go from here.
But the thing is that, as a theoretical physicist,
I've... I've hardly ever done anything besides,
you know, relying on just pen and paper and
mathematics. Um, I mean, I hardly did any
experiments in my undergrad, I would always
just try my very best to get out of labs.
And, so, I kind of, like, you know,
didn't have that in my, um, tool belt,
and that's what this series is about. I wanted
to, like, learn how to do experiments. But, uh,
now that I've done this experiment, I don't
know how to interpret it, except through my
usual methods, and that didn't work. Um, so,
I'm a little lost as to where to go to next.
I think what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
try and, um, do some computer simulations
of the stuff that I've been calculating.
I had intended to try that anyway, um,
but I thought it would just be a way to, like,
confirm the things that I already knew. But now
that I must have some sort of mistake in my... Um,
mathematics, it would be good to try and use the
computer to like actually explore what's going on.
Um, but the thing is, uh, I don't know how to
code. That's right. It's time for a learning
to code montage. I wish that this was as easy
as this video makes it look, but it was really
not. But eventually, I did get this working.
What I did was I simulated Feynman's whole
argument with all of these slices of electrons,
and I managed to show that plane waves really
do slow down in water, which was so exciting.
So the next important thing I needed to
do was show that pulses of light do slow
down in my simulation. Now, I was pretty
sure that this was going to happen because
this simulation is just based on two things.
Feynman's original analysis of plane waves,
which only basically assumes some stuff about
electromagnetism, so that seemed rock solid.
And then to upgrade that analysis from plane
waves to pulses, I used the Fourier transform
to write the pulse as a sum of a bunch of plane
waves. And then I did the [00:15:00] analysis
for each of those plane waves and then
added them back up. The Fourier transform
is a mathematical fact and so stuff based
on that is basically guaranteed to work.
I know I went on and on about how it's cheating
to use the Fourier transform before, but I think
in this case it was and it wasn't. Like, I don't
think it was cheating because I just wanted to use
it to confirm, at least mathematically, that this
model would show that light slows down in water.
Like even pulses of light would slow down.
But then, after I'd got that confirmation,
I'd figure out why that happens without using the
Fourier transform. At least, that was the plan,
except my simulation just wouldn't work.
This was supposed to be the straightforward part.
If this wasn't working, then it means that there's
something very wrong with Feynman's analysis.
I had nowhere else to turn. Like I'd read all
these other textbooks and Feynman's derivation
[00:16:00] was the only one that made any sense at
all. I mean, I'd gotten so desperate that I asked
all of my physics friends and I even started
cold emailing a bunch of photonics professors.
Yeah, nothing worked. And I had. No way to fix my
explanation and even though I'd spent months and
months on it at this point Um, I started feeling
so sick to my stomach every time I thought about
it that I decided I just needed to give up on
this project. Some months after I'd given up,
Grant convinced me that I should just make a video
about this project even if it didn't work out.
And so I revisited my old code and it was
terrible. Like I know I was a beginner but Man,
that code was so bad to read. In fact, it was
so bad that I just decided to scrap the whole
thing and rewrite it in a few days. It's
like midnight, and I'm coding, and look at
this. Those waves travel pretty fast till they
get into here, and then they're just sort of,
well, they're all over the place, but.
Okay, let me show you the simulation
that's slightly more convincing than what you
just saw. Okay, this red light gets shone into
some water. And what happens is, it continues
going at the speed c, um, but this purple light
is the new light that is resulting from the
original light plus the electron's light.
And you can see that that is going a lot slower.
And you can tell because, um, see this dot here,
the red one, is something going at the speed c,
whereas these ones are reduced ones. The blue
dot actually represents the phase velocity of
the main frequency in this light. But the green
dot represents the actual information speed
of light, and they're a little bit different
because there's a difference between basically
the group velocity and the phase velocity.
It's a little bit technical, but it's actually
kind of cool that, um, I can show you this.
I've just changed the parameters a [00:18:00]
bit, so the refractive index is less than 1.
And it actually is possible for the refractive
index to be less than 1 in real situations. Um,
but you might have thought, well, that
must mean that the speed of light is
suddenly greater than C in those mediums.
But that's not true. The phase velocity
is greater than C, but the information speed, or
like the group velocity, is less than C. Alright,
so you can see the original light coming in,
and it's still going faster than this resultant
light. But here's something interesting. See the
blue dot is going faster than all three of them.
If you follow one of the peaks of the purple
light, then you'll see that it's travelling at
this phase velocity, whereas the overall shape of
this light is travelling at the group velocity,
or the information speed of light. Here you can
see this a little bit more clearly. The blue dot
is going to keep in time with that first peak.
But the green dot keeps in time with the actual
light. And what this shows is that even
if the refractive index is greater than 1,
the information speed of light is always less than
c in a medium. I guess there were just some bugs
in my code, because now it was working and the
simulation showed that Feynman's analysis does
lead to the conclusion that the information
speed of light slows down, which is great,
until I remembered that I kind of already
knew that the information speed slows down,
right, like from the experiment.
What I wanted to get from the simulation
was hopefully some insight into why. And this
simulation, based on the Fourier transform,
was giving me none of that. For example, it
correctly showed that if you have a pulse of
light going through water, eventually the
new pulse of light will lag so much behind
the original light that's travelling at
sea, that the two will become disjoint.
This could happen is if the electron light exactly
[00:20:00] conspires to add up like this. So,
like, the electrons have to make this crazy
two peak distribution where the first peak
is travelling at the speed c, but somehow the
second peak is travelling at the speed 3/4c.
Basically, some of the electron's light has to
travel fast enough to cancel out the original
light entirely, and then some of the electron
light has to be travelling at a slower speed.
This is the only way to get around
the argument that I made earlier.
Because basically I was assuming that
you would never have this situation
where the electron light cancels out
the original light exactly. Honestly,
that felt impossible. It felt like way too much of
a grand conspiracy on the part of these electrons.
And so I just didn't believe that that could
be possible. The simulation, based on Feynman's
argument, tells us that this must be what happens,
but it gives very little insight into why,
because it doesn't really let you directly see
what all the electrons are doing. So I really
wanted to understand this exact situation.
Not the one with plane waves, but with
these real pulses of light. But the thing is,
this calculation was just way too difficult,
because you have to imagine the effect of every
electron on every other electron. And this all
simplified down really nicely when you're working
with plane waves, but it doesn't simplify nicely
at all when you're working with actual light.
And so that's where I got stuck. What I needed
to do was write a simulation that directly
models pulses of light like this. rather
than using plane waves in the background.
The problem was that that simulation would
be a lot harder to write. All right, I figured
out how to make my simulation stop blowing up,
which is very exciting, so let me show it to you.
One thing to note about this simulation is how
painfully slow it is. I tried to vectorize
everything, but, uh, I couldn't get it to work,
and so, in the end, everything is just a
for loop. What's happening here is this
red thing is the light that's entering a medium.
So the medium is represented by these electrons.
There's actually 175 of them in this simulation.
I haven't drawn them all because it gets kind of
crazy. In fact, it's It's kind of crazy with
them here right now, but I'll take them out
for the rest of them. Anyway, what's happening is
that you can see that the light oscillates these
electrons and they jiggle about, and hopefully
eventually they settle back down, but who knows.
Anyway, the more important thing is the purple
line. So the purple line is the total light, um,
so it's the sum of the red light, which is the
original, plus the blue light, which is what's
coming from the electrons. We need that purple
resulting light to be going slower than the red
original light, but let's see if that pans out.
First, let's look at the simpler case, or at
least what should be the simpler case. So here we
have the red light [00:23:00] being a plane wave,
and what we expect to see is that the purple
resulting light should be, um, like a smaller
wavelength and also should be going slower. Right
now, the electrons are acting completely crazy,
like their light is all over the place.
But, that actually kind of makes sense,
because in, um, Feynman's thing, he assumes that
the electrons are in a steady state. But actually,
it takes a little while for the electrons to
settle down. So, let's give this a second.
And now we can kind of see the behaviour that
we're expecting. You see how the purple light
now looks like it's kind of lagging behind
the red light and the gap kind of grows?
It sort of does look like the light is slowing
down, which is pretty surprising. I'll show
that to you again so you can see whether
you agree with that and I'll take out the
blue light because I think it's a little bit
confusing and I'm going to speed it up a bunch.
So for the plane waves this just about works. At
first the behavior is a little bit crazy but then
it does settle down and kind of gives you what
you expect, which is that the new light seems
to be traveling a bit slower. It's a little
hard to tell but it looks like it probably
is and it seems to have a smaller wavelength.
But for the pulse of light, I couldn't even
get it to actually slow down and I don't know why
exactly that is. It might be because I just need
to have more electrons in the simulation
and, um, more time elapsed. But, like,
this simulation is very, very computationally
expensive and I haven't been able to run it with,
like, much higher parameters than this.
So maybe that's it, or maybe there's
something more fundamentally wrong. Um, so it's
kind of hard for me to draw conclusions from this
simulation at all. Like, it kind of looks like...
The front of the, um, original light is getting
worn down by the electrons as they go through.
Which is what I suspected must be the answer.
That like, as the light travels through
the water, at every layer, the electrons
just shave a little bit off the front. More and
more until eventually that original pulse just
basically gets cancelled. I think that must
be what happens. And the simulation kind of,
kind of suggests that. But it's really not
enough to draw a solid conclusion about.
There's still so many bits that I don't
understand. And it's very frustrating because
I thought that if I wrote this simulation
that it's taken so much work that it would
just give me all of the answers. Um, instead
I just have this thing that like frustratingly
half works and I don't know what to think.
This whole thing started around Christmas of
2022 for me, and it's almost Christmas again. And
honestly, I think it's time that I admit that I
don't know why light slows down in water. I feel
awful having to admit that on a video, but I guess
I'd feel even worse if I made a video where I
pretend I know the answer and it sounds right.
But I'm kind of hopeful that maybe by telling you
why this question is complicated and interesting,
some of you might want to take it up. And
if you do, and you make some progress,
then I would really love to hear about
it. So yeah, let me know in the comments.